Lauterbach zu meiner Rechten herzlich
willkommen daneben hat Platz genommen
Professor Dr Lothar Wieler der Präsident
des Robert-Koch-Institutes aber an sehen
hat sich es bekommen und ganz außen dr
Susanne Jonas sie ist die Vorsitzende
des ärzteverbandes Marburger Bund auch
an sie eine herzliches Willkommen für
alle
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer die uns
live oder per Stream sehen wie immer die
kleine Vorbemerkung die
Bundespressekonferenz ist keine
Institution der Bundesregierung sondern
ein unabhängiger Verein von
Journalistinnen und Journalisten wir
organisieren Pressekonferenzen damit
unsere Mitgliedschaft objektiv und
fundiert über die politischen Vorgänge
in Berlin berichten kann das zur
Vorbemerkung jetzt da Lauterbach haben
sie das Wort bitteschön vielen Dank die
waren ja auch vielen Dank für die
Möglichkeit hier vortragen zu dürfen es
ist leider keine gute Situation mit der
wir zurzeit konfrontiert sind die
Pandemie ist bei weitem nicht vorbei
also von einem freedom der kann keiner
Rede sein ganz im Gegenteil wir haben im
Moment um die 300.000 Neuinfektionen und
pro Tag die Dunkelziffer ist nicht
bekannt aber es davon auszugehen dass
die tatsächliche Zahl der Neuinfektionen
mehr als doppelt so hoch ist wir
beklagen um die 300 Tote pro Tag und zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt gibt es auch keinen
klaren Hinweis der vermuten lese dass
sich diese Situation kurzfristig ändert
das könnte sogar sein dass die Inzidenz
sich noch etwas stabilisiert aber die
Zahl der Toten steigen würden in den
nächsten Wochen das ist zumindest nicht
auszuschließen somit eine Situation die
ausgesprochen unbefriedigend ist das
spiegelt sich auch in den Krankenhäusern
wieder da bin ich sehr dankbar dass frau
Kollegin Jona heute dabei ist und unser
berichten kann die Belegschaften sind
zum Teil stark infiziert in
Krankenhäusern wird berichtet dass jeder
zweite infiziert wird Notbetrieb wird
gemacht UPS werden verschoben alles in
allem also ist das eine Situation wo wir
unmittelbar und schnell reagieren müssen
und das ist auch das was ich also heute
vortragen möchte wir sind in einer
Situation gekommen wo wir nicht einfach
abwarten können wann geht das vorbei
also diese Haltung wir warten ab bis das
Wetter besser wird und dann geht das
irgendwann vorbei das reicht nicht
sondern wir müssen in diesen letzten
Wochen bevor tatsächlich durch besseres
Wetter die Inzidenzen auch
wahrscheinlich sinken werden müssen wir
noch einmal aktiv werden müssen wir noch
einmal etwas tun die können es nicht so
lassen wie es derzeit ist und ich habe
dazu also drei Punkte vorzutragen die
mir bedeutsam sind zum einen wir müssen
unbedingt die hotspot-regelung die mit
dem neuen Infektionsschutzgesetz
gekommen ist müssen wir auch nutzen
diese Regelung muss jetzt genutzt werden
das Infektionsschutzgesetz hat ja nicht
jedem gefallen und ich kann auch
verstehen wenn es da Vorwürfe von den
Ländern gegen den Bund gab und der Bund
wiederum also da zum Teil dann beklagt
hat dass die Länder in der Vergangenheit
nicht alles einheitlich gemacht haben
aber die Vorwürfe diese gegenseitigen
Vorwürfe bringen uns im Moment überhaupt
nicht weiter sondern wir müssen mit der
Situation klarkommen und
Zusammenarbeiten Bund und Länder
gemeinsam und da ist das
Infektionsschutzgesetz eine gute
Grundlage ich will nur noch mal mit
einem Satz erläutern wieso haben wir
eigentlich bei so hoher Inzidenz keine
bundeseinheitliche Regel wieso haben wir
zum Beispiel keine bundeseinheitliche
maskenpflicht jetzt oder beispielsweise
bundeseinheitliche testvorgaben
meinetwegen für die Restaurants oder so
etwas das war einfach rechtlich nicht
mehr möglich der Bundesjustizminister
Marco Buschmann hatte die rechtliche
Lage analysiert und kam zu dem Schluss
dass diese bundeseinheitlichen Maßnahmen
nur noch vertreten werden können
rechtlich vertreten werden können wenn
es auch eine bundeseinheitliche
Gefährdung der Gesundheitsversorgung
gibt oder wenn diese zumindest droht
somit wenn es also eine Beziehung gibt
in einigen Bundesländern oder in den
Bundesländern in bestimmten Orten aber
nicht bundeseinheitlich kann es keine
bundeseinheitliche Regeln ergeben das
ist die rechtliche Vorgabe mit der wir
hier gearbeitet haben beim
Infektionsschutzgesetz somit waren zum
Beispiel eine bundeseinheitliche
maskenpflicht nicht mehr beschließbar
weil es eine bundeseinheitliche
Gefährdung der Gesundheitsversorgung zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht gibt und die
hat auch der Expertenrat nicht kommen
sehen
wo ich man und ich werden uns auch mit
dem Expertenrat getroffen der das wurde
dort auch nicht angekündigt dass eine
solche Gefährdung bevorstünde somit ist
dann die Regelung gekommen
Hotspots überall dort wo die Gefährdung
gegeben ist und die Inzidenz steigt oder
hoch ist kann
der Landtag Maßnahmen ergreifen um die
Bevölkerung zu schützen und das sollte
jetzt auch geschehen wie es jetzt in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern vorgesehen also
ich habe gestern Abend Thema lange mit
Ministerpräsidentin aus
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern Manuela Schwesig
gesprochen und so wie sie das Gesetz
anwendet oder anwenden will der Landtag
dort ist es aus meiner Sicht korrekt die
Kriterien also wie die Überforderung der
Gesundheitsversorgung zu messen ist die
liegen eigentlich auf der Hand und hier
sind vier Kriterien von besonderer
Bedeutung sie betreffen alle die
Krankenhäuser weil die Krankenhäuser der
Flaschenhals für die covid-versorgung im
Sinne einer Überforderung des Systems
sind zum einen wenn zum Beispiel also
ich gehe durch die Kriterien einfach mal
durch die hier aus meiner Sicht also
relevant sind zum einen wenn die
Krankenhäuser die Notfallversorgung
nicht mehr durchgehend darstellen können
wenn Krankenhäuser Sicht von der
Notfallversorgung zum Beispiel abmelden
müssen weil sie zu viele covid-patienten
haben oder zu viele zu viel Personal
erkannt ist dann ist das ein Indiz ein
zweites in Prozent planbare Eingriffe
abgesagt werden müssen wenn planbare
Eingriffe in andere Kliniken verlegt
werden müssen also ein drittes Kriterium
oder wenn
pflegeuntergrenzen unterschritten sind
die mit diesen vier Kriterien kann die
drohende Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems belegt werden es gibt
noch mehr Kriterien aber das sind vier
Kriterien mit denen man arbeiten kann
das sind auch Kriterien die meines
Wissens in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern jetzt
vorgetragen werden das sind auch
Kriterien über die wir bei der
Gesundheitsministerkonferenz am Montag
sprechen werden denn wir müssen mal aus
meiner Sicht zu mehr Einheitlichkeit
kommen wie wir die Überlastung
feststellen so dass wir dieses
hotspot-gesetz im Infektionsschutzgesetz
besser ein anwenden können wir müssen
das gangbar machen erscheinen mir diese
vier Kriterien eine wichtige Maßnahme zu
sein wenn hotspot-re ergriffen werden
können diese ein ganzes Bundesland
umfassen so wie es in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
geplant ist dann ist die Voraussetzung
natürlich dass die Überlastung in allen
Teilen des Bundeslandes gilt das ist
klar aber wenn in allen Teilen des
Bundeslandes die Überforderung droht
oder schon da ist dann kann auch das
gesamte Bundesland ein Hotspot werden
und ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen
weil ich das immer wieder falsch höre es
hätte dort einen Lizenz zwischen
Justizminister Buschmann und mir gegeben
das ist nicht der Fall Buschmann und ich
waren uns immer einig wenn die
hotspot-regelung so ausgedehnt zum
Tragen kommt das in allen Regionen
Gebietskörperschaften eines Bundeslandes
der Hotspot ausgelöst ist dann ist das
ganze Bundesland eine gebetskörperschaft
und ein Hotspot wie es in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern der Fall aber wie
gesagt wir werden das in der
Gesundheitsministerkonferenz am Montag
im Detail besprechen
von den Hotspots geht auch ein Signal
aus für das gesamte Bundesland wenn
jetzt beispielsweise in
Nordrhein-Westfalen also Hotspots ident
identifiziert sind und dort ist der
Hotspot ausgelöst dann hat das auch eine
Signalwirkung für andere Teile des
Bundeslandes von daher appelliere ich an
die
Ministerpräsidentin und
Ministerpräsidenten diese Regel zu
nutzen es ist ja sehr
klug gehandelt worden indem man die
geltenden Regeln verlängert hat bis zum
2 April das haben fast alle gemacht aber
jetzt kommt die Zeit wo wir in einigen
Regionen sogar noch einmal Nachschärfen
müssen wo es also um mehr geht als
vorher weil wir können es so nicht
laufen lassen 300 Tote am Tag und diese
drohende Überlastung des
Gesundheitssystems sind nicht akzeptabel
ich komme zum zweiten Punkt und das ist
ein impfappell an die ungeimpften müssen
sich vor Augen führen dass sie zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt der Ansteckung so gut
wie nicht mehr entgehen können wir haben
eine so hohe Fallzahl uns alle die jetzt
ungeimpft sind damit rechnen müssen sich
in den nächsten Tagen zu infizieren das
ist leider die Situation die also eben
die man kann im Moment der Infektion
kaum ausweichen und es gibt zahlreiche
ungeimpfte die im Risiko stehen die
ungeimpften über 60 zum Beispiel die
ungeimpften die Risikofaktoren haben die
ungeimpften die eine Immunschwäche haben
die ungeimpften die eine Vorerkrankung
haben all diese immun geschwächten oder
älteren ungeimpften müssen sich aus
meiner Sicht jetzt impfen lassen es
werden viele denken bis die drei
Impfungen da sind das dauert zu lange
dann ist die Welle vorbei hier ist die
Botschaft die selbst nach einer Impfung
sinkt das Risiko schwer zu erkranken und
zu versterben nach zwei Wochen deutlich
ab manchmal schon nach einer Woche das
heißt ich appelliere an die ungeimpften
wenigstens sich noch eine Impfung jetzt
abzuholen bevor das Risiko also sich
realisiert und man ist infiziert und
erkrankt sehr schwer dass es unnötig
nichts ist unnötiger als eine schwere
Infektion mit möglicherweise tödlichem
Verlauf oder schwerer dauerhafter
Erkrankung so kurz bevor das bessere
Wetter in wenigen Wochen die Pandemie
zurückdrängt das ist einfach es macht
gar keinen Sinn dass man zwei Jahre
jetzt durchgekommen ist und sich in den
letzten Wochen dann so schwer infiziert
dass man dann tot ist oder sogar einen
oder gar einen also schweren Leidensweg
hat und dann noch verstirbt dass sie
alles was wir derzeit sehen 300 Tote
sterben ja nicht sofort das sind zum
Teil sehr schwere Leidenswege das ist
einfach unnötig daher mein Appell an die
ungeimpften sich vor Augen zu führen
derjenige der sich sagt ich bin jetzt
zwei Jahre durch die Pandemie gekommen
und habe mich nie infiziert der muss
bedenken dass das Risiko jetzt höher ist
als es je für ihn war das Risiko in den
nächsten Wochen sich zu Inf ist für die
ungeimpften größer als das Risiko sich
zu infizieren in den letzten zwei Jahren
wenn man sich das statistisch anschaut
und das ist etwas was man sich vor Augen
führen muss von daher appelliere ich
also an die ungeimpften sich jetzt hier
selbst und uns allen einen Gefallen zu
tun und die hat nur zumindest noch eine
Impfung bevorzugt zwei Impfungen
abzuholen das dritte wir müssen
offensiver mit der vierten Impfung
umgehen der Verlauf bei der Platzierung
der vierten Impfung kann nicht
zufriedenstellen wir haben also eine
13,5 Millionen Menschen die über 70 sind
für die die vierte Impfung von der STIKO
empfohlen ist wir haben eine sehr große
Zahl man weiß es nicht so genau aber
wahrscheinlich zwei Prozent der
Bevölkerung insgesamt die immundeffekte
hat wir haben aber darüber hinaus auch
viele Menschen die andere Risikofaktoren
haben schwer zu erkranken wir haben aber
insgesamt selbst wenn man es auf die
über 70-Jährigen begrenzt und die mit
immundeffekt haben wir weniger als zehn
Prozent derjenigen mit der vierten
Impfung derzeit geimpft die für die
vierte Impfungen Frage kommen 90 Prozent
derjenigen für die die sticko die vierte
Impfung empfiehlt sind noch mit der
vierten Impfung nicht geimpft darüber
hinaus sind seit dieser Empfehlung neue
Studien erschienen die auch klar belegen
dass von der vierten Impfung auch die
profitieren die noch nicht 70 sind aber
weitere Risikofaktoren haben ihr
Altersgruppe der 60 bis 70-jährigen
stellt in vielen Intensivstationen
derzeit die größte Gruppe der covet
Betroffenen also da davon sind viele
geboostet das bedeutet nicht dass die
boosterung nicht vor schwerer Krankheit
schützt die Todes aber tatsächlich ist
das Risiko wenn es auch in relativen
Einheiten klein ist weil es so viele
betrifft ein großes Risiko ich glaube
dass wir hier mehr tun könnten wir
könnten hier zum einen auf diejenigen
die von Risiko jetzt abgedeckt sind
offensiver zugehen sagen die vierte
Impfung hilft und ist hier notwendig ich
glaube aber auch dass wir auf diejenigen
zugehen sollten zumindest in der
artusgruppe 60 bis 70 die Risikofaktoren
haben von denen wir wissen dass sie das
Sterberisiko für kurvit und für den
schweren Verlauf deutlich erhöhen hier
spreche ich über zum Beispiel 60 bis
70-Jährige mit einem Bluthochdruck mit
einer Herzschwäche Herzinsuffizienz
koronare Herzkrankheit Menschen die eine
Krebserkrankung gehabt haben und eine
Chemotherapie bekommen das sind alles
Risikogruppen die stark im Risiko stehen
die sind von der derzeitigen
stikoempfehlung noch nicht abgedeckt ich
habe daher die STIKO gebeten die also
Empfehlungen noch einmal zu überarbeiten
das ist mir auch zugesagt aber in der
Zwischenzeit war ja jetzt die Welle
tatsächlich so ausgeprägt ist möchte ich
also hier meine persönliche Einschätzung
der Lage vortragen die Impfung ist ja
zugelassen als boosterimpfung auch für
diese Gruppe ich empfehle tatsächlich
jedem der zumindest in der Art als
Gruppe 60 und aufwärts der
Risikofaktoren hat koronare
Herzkrankheit Herzschwäche eine
Lungenerkrankung beispielsweise Lungen
also Fibrose oder eine COPD also
chronisch obstruktive Lungenerkrankung
Diabetes das sind ja die klassischen
Risikofaktoren auf die wir ja auch immer
bei der dritten Impfung zugegangen sind
dass wir die vierte Impfung dort
großzügiger nutzen als bis zum Teil tun
ja die vierte Impfung macht schon eine
Woche nach der Impfung einen Unterschied
und kann uns helfen mit weniger
Todesfällen durch diese schwere Welle zu
kommen mit der wir derzeit also
so Ringen haben wie gesagt ich das ist
hier keine Kritik oder Abgrenzung von
der STIKO macht eine gründliche Arbeit
wird das prüfen das zugesagt aber wir
müssen jetzt schnell handeln und daher
ist es meine Einschätzung in der
Funktion als also Gesundheit
Bundesgesundheitsminister dass wir hier
auch die 60 bis 70-jährigen mit
Risikogruppen dass das auf der Grundlage
des ärztlichen Ermessens mit einbezogen
wird das auch diese Leute sich impfen
lassen sollen wir zehn Prozent der über
70-Jährigen geimpft das ist einfach viel
zu wenig wir müssen hier mehr machen und
schließlich lassen sie mich eines noch
sagen wir haben hier oft auch an diesem
Platz aber gesprochen dass also in den
Pflegeeinrichtungen die Impfpflicht
schwer umzusetzen ist die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht in
Krankenhäusern in Pflegeeinrichtungen
und das dann die Versorgung
möglicherweise gefährdet sein weil viele
sich nicht impfen lassen das ist nicht
eingetreten die Versorgung findet statt
die also einrichtungsbezogene
Impfpflicht funktioniert die Kommunen
und auch die Länder haben eine
großartige einlastung gezeigt also in
der Umsetzung der einrichtungsbezogenen
Impfpflicht wir haben ja eine
Handreichung geboten als BMG oder
Gesundheitsministerium es wird gemacht
aber ich möchte hier mich ausdrücklich
bedanken bei den Pflegekräften die sich
hier haben impfen lassen die der ein
oder andere sogar in Zweifel was den
Nutzen der Impfpflicht angeht aber in
der Pflicht das zu machen wenn man am
Patienten arbeitet diese Menschen haben
sich auf unsere Empfehlung und auf die
Wissenschaft verlassen haben das zum
Schluss gemacht obwohl wir in der
Bevölkerung in der allgemeinen
Bevölkerung die allgemeine Impfpflicht
noch nicht umgesetzt haben daher möchte
ich mich ausdrücklich bedanken für all
diejenigen die daran mitgearbeitet haben
dass ein wichtiges Projekt weil wir
haben derzeit wieder Ausbrüche in also
den Pflegeeinrichtungen aber es ist weit
weniger als es wäre wenn die impfpote
nicht so hoch wäre in diesen
Einrichtungen daher möchte ich mich ja
ausdrücklich bedanken
Dankeschön Herr lauter auf Sabine ja die
Pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei im
Gegenteil die Fallzahlen befinden sich
tatsächlich auf dem höchsten Niveau seit
Pandemie beginnen es gibt immer noch
Landkreise mit einer 7 Tage Inzidenz die
liegt über 3.000 und innerhalb noch
einer Woche sind rund drei Prozent der
Bevölkerung mit Kurve 19 positiv
getestet worden
im Moment sind also viele Menschen krank
in Isolation oder in Quarantäne so dass
es zum Beispiel ein Arztpraxen in
Kliniken oder auch im Pflegeheimen die
schon seit zwei Jahren ohnehin massiv
belastet sind zu Engpässen kommt
und in der letzten Woche wurden
insgesamt wieder mehr als 1.000
Mitmenschen als Todesfälle registriert
in Verbindung mit Kurve 19 und das sind
natürlich fast ausschließlich Todesfälle
die im Zusammenhang mit einer
omecon-infektion stehen
omicon-infektionen verlaufen also nicht
immer mild jede Woche sterben aktuell
ich wiederhole mich mehr als 1.000
Menschen im Zusammenhang mit einer
omecon-infektion in unserem Land das
sind einfach die Tatsachen
und werden Maßnahmen gelockert damit
verändert sich das Verhalten der
Menschen es kommt jetzt sehr darauf an
wie wir uns verhalten viele die selbst
noch gar nicht betroffen waren scheinen
omecron als nicht mehr so gefährlich
oder sogar als mild einzustufen darauf
weisen die jüngsten Ergebnisse der
kosmo-befragung hin die von der
Universität Erfurt durchgeführt werden
ich möchte noch mal ganz deutlich sagen
vor allem Menschen über 60 die nicht
geimpft sind haben nach wie vor ein sehr
hohes Risiko schwer an kovit 19 zu
erkranken auch bei omecon noch mal in
der letzten Woche wurden mehr als 1.000
Todesfälle übermittelt
und zwar im Zusammenhang mit
omecon-infektion im Moment liegt du hast
Politisierung Inzidenz bei den über
60-Jährigen auf einem erhöhten Niveau
und sie steigt bei den über 80-Jährigen
weiter an und viele Menschen versterben
viele dieser Todesfälle hätten durch
Impfungen und andere Möglichkeiten der
Infektionsprävention verhindert werden
können
eine Impfung kann zwar leider nicht
immer verhindern dass man sich mit
Corona infiziert und krank wird aber sie
schützt eben in den meisten Fällen davor
dass man schwer an covid 19 erkrankt ich
sage in den meisten Fällen denn leider
gibt es auch Menschen bei denen die
Impfung nicht wie erhofft wirkt leider
können auch geimpfte an kovid 19
versterben
unsere Daten und die weltweiten Daten
zeigen aber deutlich das geimpfte
generell viel seltener ins Krankenhaus
müssen und viel seltener sterben als
umgeimpfte und diesen Effekt sieht man
ganz besonders bei den
älteren die vollständig geimpft sind und
eine Auffrischung Impfung erhalten haben
umso weniger kann ich nachvollziehen
dass immer noch rund 2,2 Millionen der
Menschen über 60 in unserem Land nicht
geimpft sind
nehmen Sie das bitte ernst schützen sie
sich lassen sich impfen auch im Hinblick
darauf dass diese Welle nicht die letzte
Kurve 19 Welle sein wird und lassen sich
auch im Hinblick auf longkurve dämpfen
erste Studie zeigen dass eine Impfung
das Risiko an Langzeitschäden zu
erleiden verringern kann
lassen sich bitte auch dann impfen wenn
sie schon infiziert waren sie verbessern
dadurch ihren Immunschutz und wenn sie
über 70 sind vollständig geimpft sind
und bereits eine auffrischeimpfung
erhalten haben dann bitte lassen Sie
sich eine zweite Auffrischimpfung geben
die STIKO empfiehlt diese
Auffrischimpfung diese zweite schon seit
Mitte Februar für bestimmte Gruppen die
ein besonders hohes Risiko für einen
schweren corona-verlauf haben dadurch
soll der individualschutz noch einmal
erhöht werden und schwere Verläufe so
gut wie möglich verhindert werden
bislang haben sie aber im
vergleichsweise wenige Menschen nur und
Minister lautebach hat es gerade noch
mehr erörtert und 1,7 Millionen haben
erst diese zweite Auffrischimpfung
bekommen
bitte nehmen Sie die Möglichkeit wahr
bitte sprechen Sie hier mit Ihrem Arzt
und ihrer Ärztin um diese zweite
Auffrischimpfung zu erhalten ich
wiederhole mich sehr gerne
wie sich den nächsten Wochen entwickeln
das hängt sehr stark von unser aller
Verhalten ab wir wir tragen die
Verantwortung für uns aber eben auch für
andere was haben was gilt für uns alle
wenn wir Symptome haben eine akuten
Atemwegsinfektion sollten wir für drei
bis fünf Tage zu Hause bleiben
und wir sollten außerhalb unseres
Haushaltes möglichst niemanden treffen
vor allen Dingen natürlich keine
Menschen mit Risikofaktoren alte
hochaltrige krebserkrankte oder auch
andere immungeschwächte
wir verhindern damit die Ausbreitung
nicht nur von Kurve sondern auch von
Influenza und anderen über die Atemwege
übertragenen Krankheiten
auch wenn sie aktuell nicht erkrankt
sind treffen sich mit Menschen die eine
erhöhtes Risiko für einen schweren
Verlauf haben bitte nur wenn Sie selbst
geimpft oder kürzlich genesen sind und
testen Sie sich vorher das
Robert-Koch-Institut empfiehlt auch
weiterhin die Regeln ah+l also Abstand
halten womöglich Hygienemaßnahmen Masken
tragen und in Innenräumen Lüften als
allgemeine Basismaßnahmen dazu gehört
auch weiterhin in Innenräumen
medizinische Masken zu tragen weil es in
Innenräumen wie wir alle wissen durch
die Aerosolbildung zur leichteren
Übertragung des Coronavirus kommt
Masken sind in erster Linie ein
fremdschutz das heißt der Masken trägt
zeigt damit auch seine Rücksicht auf
andere die vielleicht auch trotz Impfung
eine erhöhtes Risiko für einen schweren
Verlauf haben jede und jeder Einzelne
von uns kann dabei helfen besonders
gefährdete Menschen zu schützen das ist
gelebte Solidarität zu den gefährdeten
Menschen gehören zum Beispiel auch
krebserkrankte die gerade eine
Chemotherapie durchstehen oder alle
deren Immunsystem geschwächt ist und
viele andere mehr
sie alle sind mehr denn je auf unsere
Umsicht und Rücksicht angewiesen wir
können diese Pandemie nach wie vor nur
gemeinsam bewältigen und wir werden sie
auch gemeinsam bewältigen
herzlichen Dank Professor wieder
Frau Jona bitteschön ja aktuell werden
mehr als 25.000 Patienten mit positiven
corona-befund in deutschen
Krankenhäusern behandelt und das sind 60
Prozent mehr als Anfang Februar
wiederum 90 Prozent dieser Patienten auf
der Normalstation aber zehn Prozent
müssen eben auch auf der Intensivstation
behandelt werden und gleichzeitig mit
diesen deutlichen Anstieg der
Infizierten fällt immer mehr Personal
aus durch
Erkrankungen durch Quarantäne also mehr
Belastung auf den Schultern von weniger
Personal
und wir alle sind es gewohnt täglich
wöchentlich landesspezifisch die
corona-zahlen zu vergleichen als Ärztin
sage ich ihnen hinter diesen Zahlen
stehen Menschen Menschen die mit einer
schweren Infektion kämpfen Angehörige
die sich Sorgen machen Angehörige die
trauern
hinter diesen Zahlen stehen aber auch
niedergelassene Ärztinnen und Ärzte und
deren Mitarbeiter die mit großem Einsatz
versuchen die normale Versorgung
zusätzlich irgendwie aufrecht zu halten
dahinter stehen Ärztinnen und Ärzte
im Krankenhaus natürlich auch andere
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter im
Krankenhaus die seit nunmehr mehr als
zwei Jahren bei jedem einzelnen
Patienten für die Genesung kämpfen und
dabei auch noch ein riesen
organisations- und hygieneaufwand
Schultern denn natürlich ist für uns im
Krankenhaus
müssen wir unbedingt verhindern dass
andere Patienten im Krankenhaus die
vielleicht sogar unter
immunsuppressionen also Schwächung des
Immunstatus durch Medikamente zum
Beispiel aufgrund einer Tumorerkrankung
sind
dass die sich im Krankenhaus mit dem
Coronavirus infizieren muss unbedingt
verhindert werden und deswegen dieser
große Aufwand
und deswegen können auch viele
Krankenhausbetten im Moment gar nicht
belegt werden weil die Patienten
isoliert sein müssen
und selbst dann isoliert sein müssen
wenn sie eigentlich wegen einem anderen
Problem zu uns kommen aber der
corona-test dann positiv ist
stellen Sie sich vor sie tragen eine
ffp-2-maske nicht gelegentlich sondern
seit mehr als zwei Jahren durchgehend an
jedem einzelnen Arbeitstag und beim
Kontakt mit dem Patienten mit
infizierten Patienten tragen Sie dann
auch noch einen flüssigkeitsdichten
Schutzkittel und einen Augenschutz an
Visier und sie sind nach wenigen Minuten
klatschnass geschwitzt
auch die psychische Belastung des
Personals ist hoch und an freien Tagen
eignen sich Ärztinnen und Ärzte dann für
ihre Patienten noch die neuesten
wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse an
zumindest seit ich Ärztin bin hat es nie
in einem Bereich in so kurzer Zeit so
viel Wissenszuwachs gegeben
und hinter den Zahlen die wir da jeden
Tag sehen stehen auch sekundär
Betroffene es stehen Patienten
diejenigen die wir jetzt auch wieder
wegen einer
Erkrankung zu uns kommen die
verschiebbar ist ein verschiebbaren
Eingriff haben und die auch jetzt wieder
in vielen Kliniken in Deutschland eben
verschoben werden müssen
weil nicht mehr genug Personal zur
Verfügung steht die hohe Belastung zu
schultern
Ärztinnen und Ärzte sind seit mehr als
zwei Jahren in einem belastungsmarathon
und sie sind zunehmend frustriert
denn die Sorge ist enorm groß dass nach
einem Jahr hoffentlich positiven
saisonalen Effekt jetzt im Sommer wir
dann im Herbst ein dejavue-erlebnis
haben
wir haben deswegen als Marburger Bund im
vergangenen Jahr schon für eine
einrichtungsbezogene impfnachweispflicht
plädiert um die Sicherheit der
Patientenversorgung eben bestmöglich
erreichen zu können und es wäre aber
auch jetzt an allen Menschen sich selbst
und andere zu schützen
durch eine vollständige Impfung leider
sind aber erst 58 Prozent der Menschen
in Deutschland zweimal geimpft und haben
eine auffrischeimpfung erhalten und das
ist viel zu wenig
und so schwer die politische Diskussion
um eine impfnachweispflicht ist so
dringend muss sie geführt werden um im
Herbst eben nicht erneut eine
überlastungssituation zu haben und nicht
erneut einschränkt eine Maßnahme in Kauf
nehmen zu müssen und ja stimmt auch
vollständig geimpfte infizieren sich mit
dem Virus aber sie erkranken eben viel
seltener schwer Sie müssen viel seltener
ins Krankenhaus und das Risiko von
longkowitz ist geringer und natürlich
als Ärztin möchte ich Patienten schützen
herzlichen Dank für die
eingangstatements dann kommen wir zu
fragen und die erste hat Frosch
vielleicht eine Frage an Frau Dr jonath
zunächst wie erklären Sie sich das
mangelnde Interesse an der vierten
aufrichtungsimpfung hat dass damit zu
tun ist die Menschen vielleicht doch
noch auf eine extravariante für omikon
wachten oder wo dran liegt das zu wenig
informationsseitens der Bundesregierung
zu wenig Engagement der Ärzte sie
sprechen damit vielen Patienten und wenn
ich darf danach noch eine Frage an
Professor Lauterbach und etwas anderes
Thema zur Impfpflicht noch wir haben ja
gestern noch mal und hier auch noch mal
sehr sehr stark beworben sie haben sich
aber eigentlich eine Abfuhr von der
Union für die allgemeine Impfpflicht
gestern wieder abholen müssen aus ihrer
Sicht wie weit sind denn die Gespräche
gedient für eine etwas eingeschränkte
Reform der Impfpflicht der politisch im
Moment stattfindet
ja zunächst ist es sicher so dass viel
Information vorhanden ist das ist so
aber manche erreichen wir mit dieser
Information trotzdem nicht wir erreichen
Mutter nicht Muttersprachler häufig
nicht wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass
wir in Deutschland
viele Patienten gar keine direkte
Anbindung an niedergelassene Ärztinnen
und Ärzte haben und wir alle haben das
Gefühl es müssen doch alle alles wissen
weil wir uns den ganzen Tag damit
beschäftigen aber das ist immer noch
nicht so dann gibt es auch sehr
deutliche Fehlinformationen also gerade
kürzlich hat auch eine Kollegin wieder
berichtet dass ein älterer Patient bei
ihr die Auffrischimpfung abgelehnt hat
weil er gesagt hat mein Sohn hat gesagt
das ist alles Quatsch also auch Familien
setzen sich ja mit diesen verschiedenen
Argumenten die leider geführt werden
auseinander
insofern haben wir glaube ich in
Deutschland nicht so sehr ein Mangel an
verfügbarer Informationen aber wir
bekommen sie offensichtlich nicht immer
an die Adressaten die wir eigentlich
wollen
und viele interpretieren Omegon als
etwas schlimmeren Schnupfen und für
viele Patienten ist es ja auch keine
schwere Erkrankung aber wenn man diese
Masse an infizierten hat wie wir sie
jetzt leider haben in Deutschland dann
sind eben auch eine ganze Reihe an
Patienten schwer erkrankt wie man eben
an den 25.000 Patienten jetzt in
Deutschland im Krankenhaus sieht
ja euch vielen Dank zunächst einmal in
der Union das ist ja die Frage stimmt
die Union zum Schluss mit und bringt man
diese Anträge zusammen in der Union gibt
es auch sehr viele Befürworter einer
Impfpflicht an allgemeinen Impfpflicht
das ist also wird mir mitgeteilt wenn
ich beispielsweise mit Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union spreche das ist
spiegelt sich ja auch in dem Antrag der
Union wieder wo man die allgemeine
impfen ja nicht ablehnt sondern also nur
ich sage immer verschiebt
in der Hoffnung man wird sie nicht
brauchen eine Hoffnung die also aus
meiner Sicht durch nichts also gestützt
ist aber daher glaube ich schon dass wir
zum Schluss da bin ich optimistisch an
allgemeine Impfpflicht hinbekommen
werden ich glaube dass wir nachher an
gemeinsamen Antrag hinbekommen werden
also darüber zu spekulieren also wieder
aus sehr Verbote sich aber mein Eindruck
ist der das also im Parlament und das
habe ich auch gestern im Rahmen meiner
Haushaltsrede gesagt dass es im
Parlament eine Mehrheit für eine
allgemeine Impfpflicht gibt und ich
glaube dass also viele auch verstehen
was es für eine Katastrophe wäre nicht
nur medizinisch menschlich sondern auch
wirtschaftlich wenn wir im Herbst dann
erneut in eine also Situation kämen wo
wir dann das Infektionsschutzgesetz
möglicherweise Nachschärfen müssten wo
wir wieder mit Beschränkungen arbeiten
müssen wo dann also tatsächlich das
Signal kommt wir haben es nicht
geschafft wir müssen doch noch mal
einiges zurückfahren das könnte dann
auch noch eine Variante sein also die
gefährlicher ist die Angst die alle
haben ist dass die ormicon Variante sich
weiterentwickelt so dass sie auch in
tiefere Lungenabschnitte kommt das sind
nur wenige Mutationen die es bisher
verhindern und dann geht davon aus dass
die Omegon Variante von der Alpha
Variante abstammt das ist eine These die
Wahrheit wissenschaftlich von vielen
vertreten wird und wenn also diese
Mutation verloren ginge und die
omekonvariante bei der Ansteckung die
sie ja mit sich bringt dann auch die die
sogenannte transmembrane also Passage
schaffen würde in den tieferen
Lungenabschnitten dann hätten wir eine
sehr schwierige Situation darauf muss
man vorbereitet sein ich glaube dass man
das sauber dekliniert und vorträgt sind
die Chancen gut etwas hinzubekommen und
Gespräche finden auch statt auf allen
Ebenen um das zu bewerkstelligen
ich bin ganz der Meinung von Frau Jona
dass für uns fatal ist der Hinweis immer
wir milder Verlauf das hat also das ist
nicht das ist kein milder Verlauf für
die älteren das kann weder Lauf für
jemanden an immunendeffekt hat viele
Menschen wissen gar nicht ob sie ein
Immundefekt haben das ist kein Mehl der
Verlauf also auch für denjenigen der
nicht stört aber dann danach long
kovidat
lonkovit droht ja einer der wichtigsten
chronischen Krankheiten in Deutschland
zu werden und daher ist es ganz wichtig
dass wir auch dagegenhalten also
medial wird es ja leider auch also in
den in vielen Medien wird es auch so
dargestellt als wenn es eine sehr
harmlose Erkrankung wäre und da kommt
gar nicht zum Tragen das 25.000 Menschen
für kovid behandelt werden und 2500
ungefähr schwanger etwas auf den
Intensivstationen in großen Kliniken
also beispielsweise werden von
denjenigen die vor mit oder für Profit
in die Klinik kommen wir brauchen 70%
Sauerstoff das ist keine Kleinigkeit
also wenn sie vor jünger wird das
bestätigen wollen wenn ich sauerstoff
einsetze dann bin ich in einer Zone
unterwegs oder Ausgang unklar ist oder
Ausgang wirklich unklar ist und das
müssen wir noch mehr in den Vordergrund
stellen dass es keine leichte Erkrankung
ist
Dankeschön Sascha Meyer von der dpa
fragt an Sie Herr Lauterbach die Länder
tun sich erkennbar schwer mit neuen
Regeln zu Hotspots für ein nahtlosen
Anschluss ist aber ja nur die nächste
Woche Zeit kommt ab 3 april ein Freedom
Day sozusagen aus Versehen weil viele
Orts keine richtigen Schutzregeln in
Kraft sind
das glaube ich nicht also zunächst
einmal bin ich froh dass also fast alle
Länder ich glaube alle bis auf ein Land
alle bis auf Schleswig-Holstein die
Regeln verlängert haben die noch
gegolten haben und das war ja angelegt
dass man das Verkanten dass man das kann
und ich hoffe dass die Länder in der
nächsten Woche per
landtagsbeschlussverlängerungen dort wo
notwendig in den Hotspots möglich machen
wie gesagt das ist ein sehr wichtiges
Thema für unsere
Gesundheitsministerkonferenz am Montag
und ich bin auch mit einigen Ländern
übrigens im direkten Austausch wie
können wir das machen also wir müssen
natürlich auch erklären wie funktioniert
das Gesetz wie ist das intendiert also
hier ist die Notwendigkeit klar die
Länder bestreiten ja nicht dass jetzt
also andere Maßnahmen notwendig werden
denn da haben wir alle beklagt dass sie
nicht mehr an Möglichkeiten geboten
bekommen haben jetzt also kommt der
Zeitpunkt wo wir uns einfach
zusammensetzen müssen die Zeit der Schul
Zuweisungen ist vorbei also hier muss
man jetzt mit dem arbeiten was man hat
wie gesagt bundeseinheitlich Maßnahmen
konnte ich den Ländern nicht anbieten
obwohl das viel erwartet hatten weil
eine
flächendeckende deutschlandweite
Überlastung des Gesundheitssystems nicht
belegt werden konnte
Frau Kollegin
ZDF Herr Professor Lauterbach sie
betonen immer wieder dass wir die
Pandemie nur beenden könnten mit einer
allgemeinen Impfpflicht und das dann
auch die Maßnahmen enden würden können
Sie bitte mal sagen wie hoch denn die
Impfpflicht sein muss einmal zweimal
dreimal viermal geimpft damit wir die
Pandemie beenden können und wenn ich das
an Herrn Wieler das
Infektionsschutzgesetz wurde gerade
geändert es gibt jetzt nur noch einen
Basisschutz müssten dann nicht auch
Quarantäne Regeln geändert werden
ja also wir wissen dass also die
dreifache Impfung die wird ja jetzt als
Grundimmunisierung auch von der
deutschen Gesellschaft Immunologie also
betrachtet zumindest von Vorfall
Professor fagen auch kein von der
Professor Watzl aber auch von anderen
die also dreifache Impfung ist die
Grundimmunisierung nach der dreifachen
Impfung ist man vor schwerem Verlauf und
vor tödlichem Verlauf in der Regel
geschützt es gibt dann immer noch also
diejenigen also wo der Verlauf so
unglücklich ist dass also ich eben auch
ausgeführt hatte eine Fährte Impfung
also noch mal ein Unterschied macht aber
wenn alle drei Mal geimpft wären dann
hätten wir keine große also
Gefahr mehr zu bannen das ist keine
Frage und es wird derzeit auch an
Impfungen gearbeitet die gegen ommikon
also schützen aber auch gegen alle
Varianten die wir schon hatten also
Impfungen die quasi das komplette
Spektrum abdecken und diese Impfungen
also
werden wir also sehr früh haben wenn sie
auf den Markt kommen wir sind mit den
mit den also mit den Herstellern im
direkten Austausch im direkten Tag
werden auch am laufend informiert also
wie weit also die Entwicklung ist so
dass ich also zu sichern kann kommt die
allgemeine Impfpflicht haben wir die
Impfstoffe die Impfstoffe die wir
brauchen und können auch das ist ja ein
juristischen Sinne dann notwendig die
Impfung so durchführen dass sie ein
geeignetes Mittel ist um also die
impflücke die wir derzeit haben zu
schließen dann wird es immer noch eine
kleine Gruppe geben wo die Impfungen
nicht ausreichend wirken eine kleine
Gruppe geben die möglicherweise trotz
Impfpflicht also ungeimpft bleiben das
ist klar aber wir kommen dann doch in
die Situation hinein dass die mit der
also Pandemie an hergehender
Sterblichkeit und auch die damit
einhergehende Last an den dass wir das
gebrochen bekommen man muss das ja von
oben rechnen und nicht von unten wenn
sie zehn Prozent ungeimpft haben bei den
über 60-Jährigen und vergleichen das mit
einem Land wie beispielsweise England wo
der also
Anteil bei ein bis zwei Prozent liegt
dann kann man erstmal sagen 90 Prozent
98 Prozent das fängt alles mit einer
neuen an und das sind ja gute Quoten
also bezogen auf die Leute die im Risiko
stehen die also sozusagen sich
infizieren können Stärken sterben können
sind das fünf bis zehnmal so viele wir
haben fünf bis zehn Mal so viele die im
Risiko stehen wie in England derzeit und
daher also ist die Engländer haben wir
jetzt auch fast wieder 100.000 Fälle
dort steigt ja auch die Fallzahl die
müssen aber viel weniger nervös sein als
wir weil wir fünf bis zehn Mal so viele
Menschen haben die in der Altersgruppe
regelmäßig im Risiko stehen
ja das ist eine gute und wichtige Frage
ich möchte noch mal in Erinnerung rufen
dass er diese Pandemie Bekämpfung auf
drei Säulen basiert diese drei Säulen
sind die Eindämmung einfach doch
Containment genannt die sogenannte
mitigation also die Abmilderung und der
schutzprotektion und diese drei Säulen
die finden Sie im Pandemieplan der ja
unter Federführung des RKI vor einigen
Jahren mit ganz ganz vielen
Kolleginnen und Kollegen und Fachleuten
aus verschiedenen Bereichen
erstellt wurde und bei der Eindämmung
steht im Vordergrund dass man eben
versucht Infektketten zu brechen und und
so schnell wie möglich dafür Sorge zu
tragen dass ich eine reger nicht
ausbreitet das ist in der momentanen
Situation natürlich kaum noch möglich
denn wir haben ja wirklich sehr sehr
hohe Fallzahlen und darum hat das
Robert-Koch-Institut ja auch über die
ganzen zwei Jahre immer wieder die
Maßnahmen angepasst also die Quarantäne
da geht es ja darum dass Menschen die
unter dem Risiko stehen sich angesteckt
zu haben
aus dem Infektionsgeschehen rausgenommen
werden und bei der Isolation da geht es
ja darum die Menschen die positiv
getestet wurden und wir haben das
kontinuierlich angepasst und wir werden
es natürlich auch jetzt wieder anpassen
es ist ganz klar dass die
quarantäne-regelung bei so hohen
Infektionszahlen das dass das gar nicht
mehr möglich ist die wirklich stringent
durchzusetzen und ich denke es ist auch
klar dass auch die isolationsregeln
weicher werden wie das genau aussieht
das wird ja kontinuierlich verhandelt
ich denke das wird auch in den nächsten
Tagen wird es da wieder neue Beschlüsse
geben aber sie können gewiss sein dass
das RKI hat eben immer zwei Dinge im
Kopf das eine ist die Epidemiologie das
heißt also wie ist das geschehen
insgesamt in unserem Land und das zweite
ist wie ist die biologische Eigenschaft
des Erregers diese beiden Dinge werden
immer von uns betrachtet und dann gibt
es die Empfehlungen die stehen auf
unserer Website und die werden
kontinuierlich angepasst und in Kürze
auch wieder ja
aber ich habe jetzt immer noch nicht
verstanden wie hoch die Impfquote sein
muss ich habe verstanden dreimal geimpft
geht es ihnen in erster Linie um die 60
oder 70 oder 50 also wie hoch muss die
Quote in Deutschland sagen es gibt da
keinen Grenzwert also kann man nur sagen
so hoch wie möglich je höher wie die
Quote bringen desto besser geht es uns
also es gibt keinen Schwellenwert und
man sagen kann jetzt ist das Risiko
gering das hängt auch davon ab was für
eine Variante wir bekommen ich wollte
der Frage nicht ausweichen aber ich will
es einfach mal am Beispiel erläutern
also die Quote muss umso höher sein also
je höher der R-Wert der Variante ist
wenn wir jetzt beispielsweise das
bekämpfen was ich eben als Worst Case
bezeichnet habe nämlich wir bekämen die
omegon-variante die Omegon Variante
entwickelt sich aber weiter und verliert
die Mutationen die derzeit dafür sorgen
dass es in erster Linie die oberen
Luftwege sind also die betroffen der
sogenannte endosomale Zugang und der
transmembrane Zugang käme dazu in den
tiefer Lungenabschnitten dann hätten wir
dann wäre der Worst Case eingetreten
dann hätten wir eine also sagen wir
Variante die aus Amazon tödlich ist wie
Delta oder mehr und also so ansteckend
wie Omegon und dann muss ich natürlich
mit einer sehr hohen Quote arbeiten um
das zu beherrschen das ist ja gar keine
Frage käme jetzt zum Beispiel
unverändert Omegon dann wäre die Quote
niedriger mit der man arbeiten kann käme
die deltawelle zurück also dann gäbe es
wiederum oder eine ganz andere Variante
somit das ist kein fixer Wert sondern
der berechnet sich aus drei Faktoren
einfach ausgedrückt der erste Faktor ist
wie viele Leute sind was ist die
Impfquote also wie viele Leute sind
geimpft zum zweiten also wie hoch ist
der R-Wert und der also dritte wert ist
wie wirksam ist die Impfung das ist ja
auch ein Faktor den wir noch nicht
bestimmen können und also einfach
ausgedrückt also aus bestimmten System
heraus also sind sie am besten unterwegs
wenn Sie eine hohe Impfquote haben mit
einer Variante die erniedrigen R-Wert
haben und eine Impfung die sehr wirksam
ist an 100% gibt sie können aber auch
den Weg des Elends gehen und der Weg des
Elends ist ja der Weg dass sie eine
R-Wert haben dass hier hoch ist die und
die Impfquote ist aber nicht so gut und
die Impfstoffe können das nicht gut
beherrschen dann ist das einmal und
somit aus diesem Dreieck Klang ist jetzt
nicht die richtige also Metapher aber
sag mal aus diesem drei Satz kann man
das irgendwie die Formeln die dahinter
stehen sind hochkomplex das ist keine
dreisatzrechnung aber man kann
ausrechnen für eine gegebene Variante
und eine gegebene Wirksamkeit der
Impfstoffe die man hat wie hoch die
Impfquote sein muss wir wissen aber
eines ganz genau die Impfquote die wir
jetzt haben
ist zu niedrig um bei allen Varianten
die wir bisher kennen im Herbst ohne
einschneidende Maßnahmen durchzukommen
das entscheidende Satz also wenn ich
diese Berechnungen mache ich gerade hier
vorgetragen habe dann war sich das für
alle Varianten die wir bisher kennen im
Herbst wieder Maßnahmen notwendig würden
und zwar nennenswert keine Kleinigkeit
wir sprechen nicht über eine Kleinigkeit
wenn wir die impfpote nicht erhöhen ich
will nur mit einem Satz des
Gedankenexperiment zu Ende führen
stellen Sie sich vor werden die Zahl der
Fälle die wir jetzt haben wir gingen
aber am Übergang Herbst in den Winter
über mehr Innenraum schlechtes Wetter
die impf also Lücke hat sich wieder
aufgebohrt bei denjenigen die schon mal
geimpft waren und so weiter und so fort
wir hätten die werden die 300.000 Fälle
oder wir gingen jetzt in den Winter
hinein das eine lupenreine Katastrophe
und daher ist es falsch zu glauben dass
wir im Herbst gut durchkommen wenn es
nur ormicon wäre das einfach falsch und
so also arbeiten wir
unermüdlich an der also an der
Impfpflicht die also andere Länder in
dieser Form nicht so dringend brauchen
weil sie eine viel höhere Impfquote
erreicht hatten
die nächste Frage Frau Kollegin
ich habe eine frage zum Weg des Elends
auf technischer Frage bei digitalen
impfzertifikaten diejenigen die eine
corona-erkrankung hatten bevor sie
geimpft worden sind gelten ja mit
Erkrankung und einer Impfung als erstmal
grundimmunisiert und mit einer
Erkrankung und zwei Impfung eigentlich
als gebustert in fällt es aber immer
noch schwer in deutschen Apotheken sich
dieses in digitaler Form nachweisen zu
lassen weil die Apotheker nicht wissen
wie sie das technisch umsetzen sollen
wie kann diese Menschen und das sind ja
immerhin mehr als eine Million manche
von denen lassen sich dann einfach so
das dritte Mal impfen weil sie sagen ich
habe keine Lust mehr mich damit
auseinanderzusetzen aber rein rechtlich
haben sie einen Anspruch darauf ein
digitalen genesenes impfzertifikat für
ihre Erkrankung zu bekommen und den wird
derzeit immer noch technisch Ihr
rechtliches
rechtlicher sage ich mal Status nicht
ermöglicht ja ich werde das noch einmal
aufgreifen ich war also man
Kenntnisstand ist der dass es technisch
auch geht und das ist auch Apotheken
machen das ist nicht alle Apotheken
können aber das gemacht werden kann aber
ich werde das noch einmal prüfen in der
zuständigen Fachabteilung und würde
ihnen dann also noch einmal eine
bilaterale Auskunft auch geben wenn sich
an mich wenden wollten grundsätzlich ist
aber die Lage ganz klar also der also
Rechtsanspruch ist da und natürlich ist
es in der Praxis mit dem Impfausweis
möglich den Status zu belegen das ist
auch klar aber es ist trotzdem etwas was
also geprüft werden muss
ich wäre da wirklich um Übermittlung
sozusagen die Adresse der Apotheke die
das in Deutschland kann dankbar weil aus
der Recherche und auch aus eigener
Erfahrung in drei verschiedenen Städten
in über 15 Apotheken ist es nicht
möglich und die Auskunft der
militärapotheker ist immer wieder die
Apothekerverband veröffentlicht das zwar
genauso wie sie sagen dass wenn man ein
Recht hat es wird aber immer anders RKI
verwiesen dass es nicht möglich sei weil
das systemtechnisch nicht ausgestattet
sei das möglich zu machen also wie
gesagt ich prüfe das weil der vom der
also mir bekannte Sachstand ist von
Seiten der also Apothekerschaft dass das
Problem gelöst sei
aber ich also nehme ihre Anregungen mit
weil ich es tatsächlich nicht so im
Detail also hier beantworten kann und
würde ihnen dann also Auskunft geben
immer gerne verwiesen das ist auch ganz
gut aber ich kläre das auch noch mal
also meines Wissens ist es natürlich
möglich
immer der Punkt ist der das natürlich
die genesenen mit einer pcr-nachweisen
müssen dass sie eben genesen sind und
wenn das geschieht dann funktioniert das
auch aber auch gerne checke ich das auch
noch mal dann werden wir das beantworten
die nächste Frage Frau Kollegin
Eva Ellermann vom ARD-Hauptstadtstudio
meine Frage geht anderen Minister
Lauterbach der baden-württembergische
Gesundheitsminister meine lucha von den
Grünen hat ihn gestern einen Brief
geschrieben und fordert eine
Strategiewechsel Ende April nämlich von
der pandemischen Lage zur endemischen
Lage unter anderem fortet er die
anlassbezogene Tests auszusetzen und
auch die Quarantäne Regeln zu lockern
bezieht sich da auf die
Gesundheitsämter in Baden-Württemberg
haben sie diesen Brief schon bekommen
und ja was sagen sie zu dieser
Einschätzung und was antworten Sie Herrn
Luca
ich glaube dass ich diesen Brief
ignorieren werde
zumal sich ja auch der Ministerpräsident
in Baden-Württemberg also schon vom
Brief distanziert hat und also Inhalt
und
Argumente ich schätze Herrn Luca sehr
und ich glaube wir sind ich werde ich
werde die Anregung auf jeden Fall nicht
aufgreifen so viel sei gesagt und glaube
dass der Brief also möglicherweise in
einem Moment der Frustration oder des
Zorns geschrieben ist aber wir arbeiten
gut zusammen ich schätze Lochau und ich
werden ja am Montag sehen wahrscheinlich
somit alles gut aber das ist keine
Anregung die wir aufgreifen
dann habe ich noch online Angelika
Slavik da hatten sie schon was dazu
gesagt aber ich will die Frage gleich
wohl trotzdem noch mal stellen wie weit
sind die Bemühungen eine Mehrheit im
Bundestag für einen der
impfpflichtanträge zu organisieren ja es
wird also
es gibt halt also
Gespräche und ich hoffe dass wir da
erfolgreich sein werden ich bin aber
zuversichtlich
dann Frau
Hüsch als nächstes und dann Herr Fricke
Frage an Sie Herr Professor Wieler
können sie eigentlich sagen wie viel von
den Infektionen die wir im Moment haben
durchbruchsinfektionen sind oder im
Prinzip Infektionen bei nicht geimpften
auch vor dem Hintergrund der Ansage vom
Bundesgesundheitsminister das eigentlich
auf kurzer lang oder sehr kurz
eigentlich jeder der nicht geimpft ist
infiziert ist und an Frau Dr Jona noch
eine Frage an Sie sie haben ja die
Feldforschung all ihrer
angeschlossenen Ärzte in in wie vielen
Kliniken wie vielen Bereichen wie viel
Ländern ist die Situation so prekär dass
die Arbeitssituation extrem schwierig
wird durch die Erkrankungen im
Personalstamm
wenn sie in den Wochenbericht schauen
dann da stehen diese Daten ja drin also
wir berechnen ja immer die
impfeffektivität das heißt wir berechnen
sie auch für die Leute die
grundimmunisiert sind auch
Auffrischungsimpfung haben und je nach
Altersgruppe liegt das zwischen 15
Prozent und und 75 Prozent ist die
Effektivität noch das heißt also
umgekehrt das ist so ein wenn so viele
Menschen sind die mit einer
durchbruchinfektion nach
Grundimmunisierung oder nach auch eine
Auffrischung noch krank werden auch im
Haus im Krankenhaus behandelt werden bei
denjenigen Auffrischungsimpfung ist die
impfeffektivität zwischen 77 und 87
Prozent und gerade bei den alten also
bei den über 60-Jährigen liegt sie am
höchsten da ist also die Effektivität
bei 87 Prozent und bei denen die
grundimmunisiert sind ist es so dass
die bei den fünf bis elf haben bei 15
Prozent die Effektivität liegt und bei
den 60 und älteren bei 75% das heißt
also ja es gibt Menschen die infiziert
werden auch ins Krankenhaus kommen auch
nachdem sie geimpft sind aber die
imperfektivität ist eben sehr hoch das
heißt der Anteil derjenigen ist immer
noch deutlich deutlich geringer als die
dem nicht geimpft sind und ich denke das
ist die entscheidende Information weil
einfach wir wirklich nur schwere
Krankheitsverläufe und und auch
Todesfälle verhindern können wenn wir
eine sehr sehr große Impfquote haben es
gibt keine es gibt keine
100%
impfen die 100% wird und ich glaube was
auch ganz wichtig ist zu verstehen was
auch manchmal durcheinander geworfen
wird wir müssen eigentlich drei Effekte
von der Impfung betrachten das eine ist
wie gut schützt sie vor Infektion da ist
die Impfung schützt die nicht sehr sehr
gut das sehen wir ja wir haben sehr
viele Fälle bei Menschen die geimpft
sind die haben aber fast alle eine
niedrige Krankheit dann halt wirklich
eine milden Verlauf das zweite ist wie
stark schützt die Impfung vom schweren
Verlauf da sind wir effektiv und das
dritte ist eben wie stark schützt sie
dann vor Tod
jeden Tag die Effektivität immer mehr
und das ist auch das Ziel dieser
Impfungen die wurden so generiert dass
sie eben hauptsächlich die einzelnen
Menschen schützen vor einem schweren
Verlauf und der Schutz vor Übertragung
ist auch gegeben aber der ist eben nicht
so ausgeprägt
vielleicht kann ich dazu die Zahlen auch
ergänzen also amerikanische CDC Studio
hat jetzt kürzlich Zahlen genannt das
mit zwei Impfungen die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ins Krankenhaus
aufgenommen werden zu müssen etwa zwölf
mal niedriger ist und dann mit der
dritten Impfung also der Booster Impfung
noch zusätzlich dreimal niedriger also
das ist eine amerikanische Untersuchung
zu der Frage in wie vielen Bundesländern
ist die Belastungssituation so hoch in
allen Bundesländern muss man sagen die
Deutsche Krankenhausgesellschaft sagt 75
Prozent der Kliniken sagen dass sie
von ihren normalen Angeboten die Sie
leisten können Rückschritte machen
müssen das heißt nicht dass sie gleich
alle auf Notfallversorgung sind aber
manche Kliniken selbst
Universitätskliniken Universitätsklinik
Münster hat jetzt gesagt die Macht im
Wesentlichen Notfallversorgung weil so
viel Personal ausgefallen ist insofern
sind alle Bundesländer betroffen aber es
sind nicht alle Klinken betroffen aber
die allermeisten etwa 75 Prozent
GT sich das erheben wir nicht das ist
aber das Feedback passt zu dem Feedback
was wir von unseren Mitgliedern bekommen
wir haben gut 130.000 Mitglieder in
Deutschland natürlich haben wir nicht da
eine permanente Erhebung dieser Frage
aber das Feedback passt zu dem
denn die nächste Frage Herr Fricke ja
vielen Dank Herr Minister Frau Jona
gerade gesagt welche Grenzen setzten der
pandemieverlauf ihren Plänen einer
Strukturreform im stationären Sektor
ich habe sie akustisch nicht verstehen
können welche Grenzen
setzt der pandemieverlauf ihren Plänen
einer
strukturreformierten Sektor
keine Grenzen in der Tat sondern der
Verlauf also
belegt wie notwendig eine
Strukturreform ist das ist ganz klar die
Pandemie hat uns also
Stärken und Schwächen unseres
Gesundheitssystems gezeigt aber auch
unsere Krankenhausversorgung und die
Stärken muss man hier im Vordergrund
sehen wir haben eine das kann muss man
auch immer wieder sagen wir haben eine
im Vergleich zu anderen Ländern mit
einer ähnlichen Altersstruktur gute also
als gute aber niedrige Sterblichkeit es
sind natürlich Sterben zu viele es sind
zu viele gestorben das ist ganz klar und
jeder einzelne ist ein Einzelschicksal
auch da stimme ich vor Jona zu weil wir
arbeiten hier immer mit Zahlen jeder
einzelne ist eine Mutter ein Vater eine
Geschwister kennt und so weiter also das
sind einfach alles Einzelschicksale aber
wir haben Vergleich zu anderen auch
Ländern Europas haben wir also
eine geringere Sterblichkeit erreicht
und das ist unter anderem auch unserem
krankenhaussystem zu verdanken was immer
in der Lage gewesen ist auch unter
Maximalbelastung eine qualitativ
hochwertige Versorgung anzubieten das
muss man also hier erstmal mitnehmen und
das ist auch wichtig für die Reformen
die wir jetzt also anstoßen im
Krankenhaus wird eine große Reform
kommen müssen weil wir also mehrere
Probleme da also auch zu lösen haben das
fängt an also wie das System der
Fallpauschalen weiterentwickelt werden
könnte wie man also bestimmte Bereiche
abdeckt beispielsweise Kinderheilkunde
Geburtshilfe wie die Notfallversorgung
neu strukturiert werden kann wie man
also erreichen kann dass Eingriffe die
eigentlich nicht stationär gemacht
werden müssen von den Krankenhäusern
auch ambulanterbracht werden können und
so große Reihe von ganz wichtigen Fragen
wie man mit dem Personalmangel umkommt
umgeht wie man die Planung der
Krankenhäuser verbessert da werde ich in
kurzer eine Kommission
also liebe derzeit also auch vorbereiten
ankündigen die ich mit diesen Fragen
sehr intensiv beschäftigen wird und die
also auch also aus Wissenschaftlern
bestehen wird also nicht die üblichen
also Bänke der Versorgung also sondern
unabhängige wissenschaftliche Expertise
Wörter gefragt sagen wichtige Kommission
und da überlegen wir uns auch wie wir
das also machen das wird wahrscheinlich
eine Arbeitsweise sagen so ähnlich wie
beim Expertenrat das also die Kommission
durch das Haus also
begleitet wird möglicherweise wird die
also Kommission auch geleitet von
jemandem der aus dem
Bundesgesundheitsministerium direkt
kommt der aus dieser Aufgabe dann
übernimmt und ob ich selbst also ab und
zu außensitzungen häufiger dabei sind so
dass ich auch noch zeigen aber wir
werden eine große wichtige Kommission
für eine krankenhausreform in kurze also
vorstellen und die Vorbereitungen sind
im vollen Gange
ich habe noch einige online-fragen
Gisela Bräu vom gesundheitspolitischen
Informationsdienst fragt an sie Prof
Lauterbach und Professor Wieler wird
eine von Professor Stöhr und Professor
streek seit langem geforderte Studie
durchgeführt und zu ermitteln wie viele
Menschen tatsächlich genesen geimpft
oder gebootet sind und dazu die Frage an
Professor Wieler warum hat das RKI
bislang nicht so eine Studie veranlasst
die durchaus noch Aussage der genannten
Experten gut realisierbar wäre
also zunächst das sind ja jetzt
Forderungen von
einzelwissenschaftlern die ich nicht
also kommentieren kann und auch nicht
kommentieren möchte wir haben ja unsere
also Beratung professionalisiert durch
den Expertenrat in dem auch also
Professor streek dabei ist aber auch
Herr Wähler und ich sitze selbst auch in
diesen Sitzungen darin da also wurde der
in den bisherigen Empfehlungen des
expertenrats in den schriftlichen aber
auch in der Diskussion also wo der
Vortrag wurde der Vorschlag jetzt noch
nicht an uns herangetragen und
einzelvorschläge von Herrn Stör oder von
Herrn Steg kann ich hier nicht
kommentieren
also es wäre schön wenn die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen auf der Website des RKI die
Studien anschauen die wir ja transparent
auch veröffentlichen und auch wirklich
jedem zugänglich machen also eine Studie
wir machen insgesamt also alleine wir es
gibt ja natürlich auch viele andere
Wissenschaftlerinnen Wissenschaftler in
Deutschland die Studien machen aber wir
machen eine Studie und das ist die ist
schon einmal publiziert letztes Jahr mit
dem soziökonomischen Panel zusammen das
ist eine Studie die hatten sehr sehr
hohen repräsentativen Wert und das ist
eine Studie in der wir
herausfinden wie viel Menschen in
unserem Land eben geimpft sind bzw
genesen sind die Studie wird gerade die
die zweite Phase dieser Studie die
Proben haben wir bis Ende Februar 2022
genommen diese Studie wird jetzt
ausgewertet sie ist anspruchsvoll das
sind große wichtungsfaktoren drin weil
wir eben wirklich auch kleine Gruppen in
der Gesellschaft repräsentativ erfassen
wollen das heißt diese Studie wird
durchgeführt wir selber das
Robert-Koch-Institut
möchte seit längerem eine sogenanntes
rki-panel durchführen eine Studie die
repräsentativ kontinuierlich eine hohe
Flexibilität hat wir führen ja drei
Studien durch in Deutschland
kontinuierlich die kickstudie wo wir uns
Kinder und Jugendliche anschauen wo wir
auch diese Jugendlichen untersuchen auch
bio-proben gewinnen um den
Gesundheitszustand darzustellen das ist
eine der
besten Studien die sie weltweit finden
auf den Gebiet sind rund 14.000 Kinder
und Jugendliche diese Studie machen wir
seit vielen Jahren über kontinuierlich
publiziert sie machen die
befragungsstunde jeder und geht es und
das heißt also deutsche Studien werden
durchgeführt aber der Wunsch ist
natürlich dafür ein ein Panel haben das
dann immer
flexibel angepasst an die jeweilige
Situation bestimmte Gruppen in den
Mittelpunkt dann nimmt das ist zum
Beispiel wäre das jetzt im Falle der
Ukraine
geflüchteten möglich dass man dann ganz
konkret die dann noch in so eine Studie
einplant wir haben diese Möglichkeiten
und wir würden die auch gerne ausbauen
aber nochmal wir machen eine Studie mit
binomischen Panel wo wir genau diese
Frage beantworten dass der erste Teil
der Antwort und nochmal die Bitte an die
Kollegen und Kollegen einfach die
Informationen die auf der Website des
RKI sind auch um einzusehen es ist dann
vielleicht manchmal leichter inhaltlich
fachlich zu diskutieren und eine zweite
Aspekt ist der es ist natürlich nicht so
trivial immer zu wissen was unterwegs
ist und wir machen eine Modulierung
Studie wo wir unseren Hand der Daten wir
haben ja alleine 4 also nur wir alleine
wir machen vier serologische Studien
aber wir haben ja einen Observatorium
auch übrigens über unsere Amtspflichten
in aus dem Observatorium aufgebaut wo
wir alle Studien die in Deutschland sind
regelmäßig Monitoren wo alle die
Interesse am reingucken wir machen eine
Modulierung die werden wir auch glaube
ich in oder bin ich sicher ein kurze
publizieren anhand dieser Modulierung
mit den Daten die uns zur Verfügung
stehen werden wir auch einen Einblick
geben wie viel Menschen in welchen
Altersgruppen mit einer bestimmten
Wahrscheinlichkeit infiziert waren bzw
eben geimpft sind also Antigen Kontakt
haben das sollte in den nächsten Wochen
auch publiziert werden auch das nur zur
Kenntnis wie gesagt es wäre schön wenn
man einfach manchmal die Informationen
wirklich seriös und ergebnisoffen sucht
die schon vorhanden sind Sascha Meyer
von der dpa fragt noch mal Sie Herr
Lauterbach würden sie es begrüßen wenn
Supermarktketten oder große Veranstalter
nach Hausrecht weiter maskenvorgaben für
Ihre Innenräume machen oder verwirrt das
die Bürger nur nein ich würde das
begrüßen das ist gar keine Frage
wenn das stattfinden würde sehr eine
Ergänzung der hotspot-regel und bei der
also dabei bei einer großen Zahl von
Infektionen die wir derzeit haben also
würde ich also eine solche
Initiative sehr selbstständig auch
begrüßen noch eine Frage an Sie ja
Lauterbach nachdem und zwar von Patrick
Holstein von Apotheker tok nachdem die
Kassen erklärt haben die Abfrage bzw
Dokumentationen nicht umsetzen zu können
es geht Thema Impfpflicht planen Sie
wieder mit einer Fassung in Apotheken
ich glaube dass also die Kassen hier das
Recht haben also ihre Bedenken
vorzutragen aber diese Bedenken also
haben mich nicht also dahingehend
überzeugt dass die Kassen also hier die
Aufgabe nicht übernehmen können oder
sollten die Argumente sind ja auch schon
in der Öffentlichkeit so vorgetragen
worden das waren der hilfsargumente muss
man sagen dass wir in Europa nicht zu
bestreitende papiermangel wurde
vorgetragen oder dass man also das
Personal nicht glaubt zu haben ich
glaube nach wie vor dass eine Abfrage
über die Krankenkassen sehr sinnvoll
sein kann und daher also
schaue ich der ich bin zunächst mal kein
Antragsteller sondern kann das nur
kommentieren als an Unterstützer einer
der Anträge aber ich hatte es nach wie
vor für eine gute Idee die Krankenkassen
in die Umsetzung einer allgemeinen
Impfpflicht einzubinden
und dann habe ich noch eine letzte Frage
an Sie Herr Lauterbach von Charlotte
kurz von der pharmazeutischen Zeitung
und zwar
sie fragt
Bundesgesundheitsminister wann kommt der
erste wirkliche Entwurf zum GKV
finanzstabilisierungsgesetz ist damit
weiter in einer Erhöhung des
kassenabstands geplant
und sie bemerkt noch die Absenkung der
Mehrwertsteuer auf Arzneimittel ist
nicht im ampelkoalitionsvertrag
vorgesehen warum soll sie jetzt trotzdem
kommen
genau wir sind in der Vorbereitung also
eines
gkv-finanzierungsgesetzes und es wird
vorgestellt werden auch hier in der
Bundespressekonferenz wenn wir soweit
sind aber zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt macht
es keinen Sinn Zwischenstände
vorzutragen das einzige was ich sagen
kann ist dass wir eine besonders
ausgewogene
Belastung die ja notwendig sein wird
planen möchte nochmal darauf hinweisen
also dass die Krankenkassen das Defizit
also von
voraussichtlich 16 einhalb vielleicht 17
Milliarden Euro haben
das also im nächsten Jahr das hängt auch
sehr stark damit zusammen dass die
Krankenkassen sich sehr also
stark
engagieren mussten in der Bewältigung
der kurvit-krise sie haben Einnahmen
Einbrüche gehabt viele also Leistungen
sind über die Krankenkassen abgerechnet
worden die also zusätzlich entstanden
sind die also Krankenkassen haben daher
einen wichtigen Beitrag geleistet dafür
dass wir gut durch die Pandemie gekommen
sind bisher zumindest also bisher
zumindest also wir sind ja nicht durch
die ist nicht zu Ende und der Herbst ist
ungewiss aber das was wir bisher
geschafft haben was haben wir auch mit
der Hilfe der Krankenkassen geschafft
und das den Krankenkassen daher also
erhe Defizite entstanden haben das ist
der Preis für eine gute Versorgung von
der wir alle profitiert haben geil
werden wir die also Lasten die jetzt zu
tragen sind auch viele Schultern
vertragen also verteilen und dazu zählen
Effizienz Reserven dazu zählen Rücklagen
der Krankenkassen dazu zählen
zusätzliche Steuermittel dazu zählt aber
auch eine Belastung der Beitragszahler
wenn das sich auf diese vier Bereiche
verteilt dann bekommen wir da eine faire
und gute Verteilung hin und können auch
dieses Problem gemeinsam meistern
dann sehe ich keine Fragen mehr wir sind
durch mit der Pressekonferenz ich
bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei Frau Jona
Herr Lauterbach fürs Kommen und schließe
die Pressekonferenz